so we're here at the freedom formula  intensive uh a bunch of people is it i  know we're in 20 minutes in but it's  been good so far  and uh what's your name ma'am  why are you here what's going to happen  i'm here because i'm going to sell my  first deal this week  [Applause]  so what do you need what do you need  from me to make that happen  i need the confidence when i'm working  out the numbers and i'm trying to work  out one of my deal stacks part of me is  just like  does it does it not but i'm here to get  the confidence yes to know and have  faith in my deal so that when i'm  presenting them to my investors they  have the faith in me that i'm going to  give them a good return got it i believe  i believe that that can happen what do  you guys think  i think we can do that we'll find out  see part two of the video see part two  of the video baby